cette vidéo est faite en partenariat
avec faire phone plus d'informations en
fin de vidéo il ya quasiment un an jour
pour jour à un peu moins d'une semaine
près je sortais cette vidéo sur youtube
c'est tellement triste
franchement c'est tellement triste
mais des fois
une fois l'amour suffit pas ça fait un
an que ma vie a radicalement changé il
ya une image que j'aime bien c'est celle
du jeu des serpents et des échelles en
gros si avancer dans la vie c'est suivre
un schéma classique de se mettre en
couple puis fonder une famille et ses
bains gm montait pas mal d'échecs
j'étais assez avancé en fait dans ce jeu
la plus avancée que ce que je vous
montrais sur les réseaux et puis je suis
un serpent quoi et je redis aujourd'hui
à la casse est libre
et je me suis retrouvé tout seul j'ai
pas tant de soucis que ça avec la
solitude vous le savez j'ai fait une
vidéo sur le sujet y'a pas si longtemps
que ça j'en ai aussi parlé lors de mon
voyage au népal
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose avec lequel je suis
à l'aise mais là y avait un manque
patent qui avait un manque en fait il y
avait un surplus eva un surplus et je
savais pas quoi en faire un surplus
d'amour dans une vie de couple j'aime
bien faire des surprises de temps en
temps un des petites attentions ce genre
de choses voilà je suis je suis une
énorme merde pour tout ce qui est tâches
ménagères mais avoir une petite
attention en gestes tendres est ou ce
genre de choses bah je suis là quoi et
là bas à part quand je croise le chemin
d'une fille pour une nuit et une matinée
voir un petit peu plus eh bien
j'ai un surplus d'amour quoi est ce
surplus ils restent sur les bras et puis
c'est passé un truc c'est que j'ai dû
décorer mon appartement
et j'ai acheté des plantes
j'ai toujours tuer mes plantes tout je
suis dans mon précédent appart le
premier j'ai eu quand j'étais seul j'ai
chopé une plante morte j'en ai racheté
une morte mon précédente à pattes dans
lequel je vivais avec mon ex il y avait
des plantes mais c'étaient les siennes
quoi et moi j'ai touché pas du tout en
fait ça m'intéressait pas du tout je
m'en fichais des plantes là par défaut
j'emménage et je me dis que rien d'avoir
un petit peu de vie dans cet appartement
est donc on va prendre des plantes sauf
qu'entre le moment où je tue mes plantes
et maintenant
il ya quelqu'un qui a pris beaucoup de
place dans ma vie
et ce quelqu'un c'est tanguy tanguay
mois on a vite été très proches depuis
longtemps et même si le dira pas
forcément parce qu'il n'est pas toujours
à l'aise avec ces sentiments on s'aime
très fort ce mec est un génie des
animaux
il est un génie ça je le savais par
contre je savais pas à quel point c'est
un génie des plantes et donc il m'a
accompagné dans mon adoption on est
partis aller chercher des plantes et on
a rempli mon appart et là je me suis dit
ok c'est bon j'ai mes plantes sauf qui
s'est passé un truc inattendue ma
relation aux plantes a changé en rotant
guim dit mec t'es plante là au fond ton
salon elles ont passé luminosité c'est
pas ouf elles sont pas bien quoi elles
vont pas mourir mais
elles n'ont pas des conditions optimales
quoi moi je disais oui mais en fait près
de la fenêtre
c'est un lieu de passage c'est pas du
tout pratique j'ai pas les mettre là
quoi et au pire même si elle meurt bages
en racheter d'autres responsables et là
il se passe un truc c'est que je vois
comment tanguy s'occupe de ces plantes
je vois comment les gens s'occupent de
leurs plantes et je me dis à temps j'ai
toujours ce surplus d'amour là en fait
c'est tout simple je vais le rediriger
vers les plantes mes plantes je vais les
mettre trop bien les gens qui me
connaissent savent que quand je me mets
dans un truc généralement je fais pas
semblant j'y vais à fond et avec les
plantes c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé peut dire cyrus que tu es tombé
profondément dans l'addiction ou est-ce
que tu oses qu'on peut dire que tu es
encore raisonnables où ce mot ne
fonctionne plus du tout
aa déjà j'ai commencé par détruire ce
que j'avais comme idée préconçue sur les
plantes notamment un truc qui faisait
que soit gens n'achetaient pas soit je
les tue à chaque fois c'est l'arrosage
arche en train de réaliser que cette
vidéo commence à ressembler à un tuto
plantes c'est pas du tout ce que c'est
mais je suis quand même obligé de passer
par là pour vous montrer tout le
processus et toute la réflexion qui est
derrière ok mais reste et ça va être
intéressant à chaque fois
dans les boutiques jardinage ou sur
internet je vois toujours arrosée deux à
trois par semaine ou arroser toutes les
semaines une fréquence comme ça ça n'a
aucun sens c'est de la merde voilà je ne
dis pas souvent ça sur ma chaîne mais ça
c'est de la merde le truc est simple
vous prenez votre doigt vous l'enfoncer
genre d'une phalange cammas est en gros
en gros si c'est sec vous arroser si
c'est encore humide vous attendez
pourquoi ça n'a aucun sens parce que
votre plante en fonction de sa masse
racinaire donc c'est à dire de son
nombre de racine en fonction de la
luminosité en fonction de la température
etc elle va pas consommer l'eau de la
même façon et quand je dis de la même
façon elle va pas la consommer à la même
vitesse donc il faut s'adapter à la
plante et pour s'adapter à la plante il
faut l'observer il faut l'écouter et moi
qui ne savaient pas où mettre mon
attention
j'ai trouvé tout simplement mes plantes
chaque jour les observer être à leur
écoute et répondre à leurs besoins quand
je vous dis je me mets à fond je me mets
à fond l'eau par exemple bon l'eau du
robinet de données du calcaire il ya du
chlore si je vaporise du coup ça laisse
des traces c'est mort il faut de l'eau
la plus pure possible
du coup qu'est ce que je fais j'en parle
à tanguy d'anguilles me dit mais qu'il
faut un osmoseur ok je prends un
osmoseur j'installais un de ce
poseur dans la salle de bain cette eau
jallet spur tel quel non je bouge ce
thème et plantes on va mettre de
langatte dans l'humidité ambiante de mon
appart et suffit non je chope un
humidificateur vous souvenez du poème de
luminosité qu'à cela ne tienne on met
des lumières artificielles et ça c'est
un truc que ça m'a d'ailleurs
retourné le cerveau quoi j'avais pas
compris en fait que juste les plantes et
j'ai juste besoin de lumière les a pas
forcément besoin du v et c'est juste
n'importe quelle lumière fait le taf
évidemment il ya certains types de
lumière certains spectre lumineux qui
sont plus efficaces que d'autres
notamment pour certaines phases de
croissance de la plante on va pas
rentrer dans ces et ailleurs et les
plantes elles sont dans de la terre non
non je fabrique mon propre substrat à
base de fibres de coco je deviens dingue
je deviens maboul ok je passe mon temps
à me renseigner sur les plantes tout le
temps sp truc de ouf qui fait que ça
m'encourage à m'investir autant c'est
qu'elle me le rende elle me le rende
parce qu'elles sont viables et parce
qu'elles poussent et poussent tout le
temps et pour la première fois de ma vie
j'ai besoin d'apprendre dans un domaine
et que les répercussions elles sont
immédiates et que je le vois autour de
moi
et ça pour mon estime de moi
après pas un événement comme une rupture
ça me fait du bien
ça me fait du bien de savoir que je vais
peut-être pas une si grosse merde que ça
mais il faut comprendre que je suis
parti loin dans le délire genre pour
vous donner un exemple voilà ça pouvait
m'arriver de laisser trois appels en
absence à tanguy à 1h du mat pour
essayer de comprendre un truc sur lequel
se mêlent magnésium et ensuite trois
autres le matin à 10h du mat oui c'est
du harcèlement et l'ouïe jouent en
excuses
tanguy jeu désuet en quelques mois je
passais de jeu tu mets plantes à je
m'achète une montée ravary catathai
constellation a350 balle est d'ailleurs
en ce moment elle en train de me sortir
une feuille qui va être incroyable et ça
me procure des émotions de dingue ça
m'en fous de joie mais au-delà de ça ces
plantes et le fait de les voir tous les
jours ça change ma conception du monde
sur plein de trucs une plante oui c'est
animé mais à la fois c'est quasiment
unanime et ses actifs parce que ça va
chercher la lumière et l'humidité avec
des racines aériennes et c'est intense
et passifs parce que d'une certaine
manière ça subi son environnement et
surtout bien qu'on la fasse mourir un
peu trop souvent c'est une certaine
manière
immortel c'est que tant qu'on souviendra
à ses besoins le truc va pousser pour
toujours on peut même le léguer de
génération en génération c'est
incroyable c'est un d'elf le truc j'ai
fait lire ce passage du script à tongi
qui m'a dit attention il ya certaines
plantes qui meurt après floraison ok on
a compris le délire donc en gros à la
pâte fin mais encore mieux chaque
élément de la plante et indépendant jeu
on peut couper une partie de la tige
leur planter et genre cette partie de la
tige va à la fois développer des racines
et à la fois développer des feuilles à
30 ans j'ai découvert la beauté de la
nature au fin fond mon salon à paris et
ça m'a fait un bien fou ça m'a fait un
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable c'est
un miracle je vu le mirail de la nature
je pense qu'il ya des gens qui regardent
cette vidéo qui viennent d'eux qu'ils
vivent peut-être pas dans une mégalopole
parisienne par exemple et 19 se dire ce
mec est malade en fait ce mec n'est
jamais allé en forêt je suis allé en
forêt ok mais c'est pas pareil quand on
est vraiment quand on est vraiment genre
je rigole parce que je ça me fait rire
de m'imaginer dire je suis elle en forêt
des genres le mec qui rassure vraiment
les gens si si je je sais ce que c'est
un arbre oui je sais ce que c'est un
arbre mais le fait de le voir vraiment
tous les jours tous les jours
constamment voir l'évolution et c'est ça
j'avoue j'avais pas eu cette expérience
quoi je pense que je comprends et des
petits il m'a fait mais on avait un
jardin mais finalement assez ton la plus
et je pense que j'avais pas là j'en fait
de m'intéresser à ces choses à ce moment
il y avait la gamecube avec super smash
bros melee elles m'ont appris d'autres
choses aussi comme le fait par exemple
d'accepter l'incertitude et
l'imperfection une feuille par exemple à
une tache jaune ou une tâche brute une
tache noire
qu'est ce que c'est peut être ça peut
être une attaque de parasites ça peut
être une carence je sais pas on sait pas
on fait ce qu'on peut on est attentif et
en garde mes incertitudes et du coup
cette fée bat maintenant est la parfaite
ça rendra moins bien sur instagram c'est
pas grave c'est un peu plus moche que
les autres fai tant pis en fait j'en
prenne mon cerveau a accepté plein de
valeurs de choses qui sont importantes
pour moi comme voilà accepter la
perfection accepté l'incertitude et
surtout accepter l'impermanence en fait
là où elles m'ont aidé c'est certes
elles ont pu recevoir cette attention
que j'avais et que j'avais à offrir mais
je crois qu'il faut que j'aille plus
loin que ça
et que je sois honnête avec moi même
c'est pas que j'avais trop d'amour à
donner enfin si mais y avait autre chose
derrière autre chose de plus
égocentrique et je crois que c'est la
chose la plus intime que je vais dire
sur cette chaîne youtube même si ça on
n'a pas forcément l'air mais ça l'est je
crois que j'ai besoin de me sentir utile
pour exister en fait comme si si je ne
servais pas quelque chose je ne méritais
pas d'exister et je pense que c'est pas
anodin que ma chaîne youtube ce soit une
chaîne de vulgarisation de transmission
pareil d'ailleurs pour la chaîne de
l'antisèche
plutôt que une chaîne de divertissement
quoi et je crois qu'en fait depuis
plusieurs mois mais planta me permets de
ça même si je suis seule terre qu'elle
me permettent d'être utile de montrer
mon utilité alors c'est pas tout rose
parfois il m'arrive d'oublier les
arroser et que parfois ce soit fatale il
ya par exemple une à deux semaines j'ai
perdu mes plantes j'aimais beaucoup un
piper en atom qui était superbe voilà
c'est un peu chiant parfois j'ai des
attaques de parasites aussi j'ai une
attaque de fripes ce ceux qui me suivent
sur instagram on pu voir toutes les
mésaventures liés à ces fritz
voilà c'est tout c'est pas tout rose
c'est pas toujours facile voilà mais ça
vaut le coup cette vidéo elle fait en
partenariat avec fun et c'est pas pour
rien parce que vous le savez un des plus
gros impact négatif sur notre
environnement c'est notre
surconsommation et notamment notre
surconsommation technologique en qu'on
n'achète plein de nouveaux produits et
on recycle pas forcément les anciens
faire fun c'est une entreprise
néerlandaise qui vend des téléphones du
même nom mais ils ont une particularité
c'est que les éléments du smartphone
sont pensés pour être facilement réparés
ou mises à jour en gros sur un téléphone
classique si votre caméra et péter basse
et très difficilement réparable va
falloir souvent un nouveau téléphone
alors que là il suffit de changer le
module caméra là ils sortent le faire
phone 4 pouces et celui ci il est fait
avec plein de matériaux recyclés il est
neutre en termes de déchets
électroniques il est garanti 5 ans sur
le site vous avez donc une section
pièces de rechange vous pouvez acheter
séparément donc plein de pièces de
rechange en fait par exemple je sais pas
le module haut parleurs ou le module
caméra etc l'échangé donc s'ils sont
cassés pour les réparer mais aussi si
par exemple un moment et sortent une
meilleure caméra au lieu de racheter un
téléphone pour la meilleure caméra ou
changer juste le module quoi et donc
c'est fait pour et un sourire y perd
facilement alors techniquement du coup
on peut recharger son téléphone en 15
secondes puisqu'il suffit d'avoir une
batterie à 100% on enlève on change la
batterie on la remplace on remet parfois
ça durait qu'un second ce que j'aime
avec ce projet est d'ailleurs j'ai suivi
tout premier kickstarter d'ailleurs dû
faire fondre un maison que c'était
incroyable voulait peut-être déjà vu
rouge à ce moment là parce que ça va ça
va pas mal baisées mais ce que j'aime
avec ce projet c'est que surtout ça
donne l'exemple et j'espère que ça va
inciter les autres constructeurs en fait
suivre le même modèle qui
qui est un modèle beaucoup plus durable
pour être juste notre planète et donc à
partir du 18 novembre
il est disponible en exclusivité chez
orange jusqu'au 31 décembre voilà je
vous mets reliera en descriptions et au
niveau des petites précisions qu'est ce
que je peux vous rajoutez donc il ya
deux caméras une bière normale une un
peu plus grand angle et à un capteur qui
aide ses caméras pour des situations où
il n'y a pas assez luminosité etc voilà
il ya un lecteur d'empreintes digitales
ils chargent hyper vite j'ai chargé tout
à l'heure en usb c'est il est sous
android est tout de suite une photo que
j'ai prise de nuit tout à l'heure avec
cet appareil et son prix de vente
conseillé est un petit peu plus de 550
euros il me semble et pour moi ce genre
d'achat c'est pas tant pour les
spécificités genre la puissance de la
caméra et c'est ce qu'on veut juste et
que ça fasse le taf et ça fait le taf
c'est plus à un un acte citoyen -
c'est une manière de voter en fait c'est
une manière de voter par la consommation
je trouve donc voila merci beaucoup
faire faute d'avoir sponsorisé cette
vidéo ça fait plaisir d'avoir ce type de
sponsors sur la chaîne merci à tanguy le
sens de la veine d'avoir été
d'une si grande aide pendant tout ce
temps sur la science et sur ces quelques
mois là sur les plantes de l'avoir été
et de l'être encore et je pense que tu
le sauras pendant longtemps en tout cas
j'espère
j'en profite aussi pour remercier stouff
de nature atom un pote de tanguy le
temps qu'il m'a présentée qui pareille
me donne des tips quand il peut et
surtout merci à mes plantes voilà qui
sont toujours là et qu'ils acceptent que
je ne leur donne pas de prénom love
peace
ciao oui si vous voulez découvrir toute
ma collection de plantes seulement sur
instagram j'ai une story elle a une qui
s'appelle plantes voilà donc
tout est là